welcome to this video playing plague off
rocks from the US yeah I definitely have
in clayton before yeah two times two
wins sounds like a good statistic let's
see okay we probably get the tirage
Queens gambit terrace oh very early very
early see form yeah be three years the
normal reaction probably should be
played also here yeah but this should be
quite and quite nice for wide very often
I need to do to make some sort of
concession to let him to get him to take
until you did this um voluntarily ah
should I play Bishop e3 or it could also
be an idea to just get rid of the knight
on f6 to to get this to get this
structure with the pawn on d5 being the
weakness the bishop on f6 can easily
turn out to be a not very not very
effective piece here Bishop to e6 and
now night to d2 I guess 92 maybe Knight
a5 maybe he's just just in time to do
that
okay I'm keeping I'm trying to to
prevent be five so that i can drop back
all so that i can drop back to h oh yeah
but a play 92 at the end it would be
tricky for you but this d5 pawn is dead
turkey now queen a true threatens to win
the pawn he can just not defend it
interesting rookie one threatens 95
isn't this annoying hmm interesting I
look the 80 can play 95 rock d 50 came
so night efore is probably probably
nonsense straight
hmm
maybe really queen bee to Queen B 2 B 3
okay let's let's get out of this group
see a drug c1 or look III Roxy one looks
better and far more natural yeah but
isn't this business spawn almost gone
queen bee three queen bee three how do
you and how do you protect the poor now
looks before I think I can take
look see 495
yeah I just played it very simply with
this concept of getting to d5 still I
don't see how we defend that just don't
see a defense key fob b5 I just take
night c49 txt five yeah night xt5 isn't
this just playable 95 books you want
looks you want the ISIS in this pin
which takes Bishop takes so what's so
winning can I just grab this thing
Bishop takes d5 I play Bishop takes d5
not rook takes you four with the self
pen Bishop takes however looks very very
problematic I'm also attacking f7 here
young 25 Quincy for check and here I'm
having this big pressure yeah I can take
on b7 here and unclean a for I have
Queen f7 this is a maid funny funny
chick made I come on take on air for ya
Queen f7 and made right Luke textbook
see Aiden can you can just check play
some Desperados that's a neat finish and
I have don't have to fear the time issue
black resigns now we must take then not
that thick yes eh and he can just check
mate give away some pieces to delay the
to delay the major fun the end yeah I
tried a plate in a very very simple
fashion probably probably something that
he could have exploited but I tried try
to really keep it simple my idea is
simply I have one sorry 11 ps2 ps3 ps4
Miller four pieces that can attack d 5
while he only has three two defended the
bishop on f6 is useless ended aspect and
I was just trying to finally attack the
porn so often that she has troubles
offended but probably he made some
mistake there yeah a six is a mistake
after queen bee three he he will lose
the pawn he needs to play rook see for
him with an equal game yeah it would be
surprising if black is in trouble here
he still has decent piece activity 92
yeah this was was an idea that i also
had anything
game sorry night f4 yeah and possibly
rook c4i but you can play in this one
ugly looking but it has a very direct
purpose that's controlling the central
square a black has enough activity from
pretty clear I can do something like
this and now try to play with my Center
where this also has clamped Arawa has
increased this bishops potential
activity yeah so this was a problem
after queen bee three he has a hard time
to to cover he can try this just just
back you know night night 92 maybe so
oops not that to f4 yeah this is this is
more convenient for wide computer also
has died has this move with this idea
very nice point as this and it's not so
clear how good this is for white it's
it's probably good it is good for white
but how much it is okay well in the game
this is this is very clearly good for
white maybe yeah this isn't this chapter
exactly the toughest defense but very
hard to turn to play anyway yeah he is
his lost in any case this was nice so
everything like the checkmate okay
thanks for watching